today's topic so we always talk about
you know dating topics and stuff like
that but you know
dating could look a little bit different
in different places so now we're going
to go to the uk
to see how life is different over there
how are you hello what's your name
please frankie
i like black men i don't know why i like
black and white's race man
frankie oh my we're off to a very bad
start aren't we
we're really off the bat start i don't
know what to say to you
but frankie just just you you don't know
why you like black men
maybe you should just dig into that and
just you know
know why you have that kind of fetish
anyways let's
roll on shall we i don't know why i like
black and white's raise men it's because
i really want to be mixed race
so i put so much fake tan on
me sideways that's exactly what the it's
exactly
bollocks mate yeah it's exactly that
yeah you just want mixed race kids
god damn it
let's go frankie's never been short of
admirers
but mr right is proving elusive
i like your trout thanks
thank you i do have a high sex drive
definitely
most relationships i've come out of have
been really hurt soon now i just have
like
friends who we just basically
what would you have i don't know i need
something that's not going to make me
really pissed
what do you normally drink i think i'm
going to go for gin and tonic because
i'm quite good on that
yeah i'm definitely too scared of being
here this is why i go around
you know because or whatever because i'm
not going to be hurt if i do that
[Music]
i'm just fed up of it yeah i think i
want a boyfriend
but i've lost all faith that there's a
gentleman out there that actually
has a heart and that doesn't isn't like
all these guys she basically just said
i don't think there's any black men who
are a gentleman out there because you're
looking for the wrong things baboo
you're sophie do you think it's bad that
she's looking for black men not what i
said what did you say what i'm saying is
that if you're just fixated on the color
because you want to have kids
maybe you overlook other that's all i'm
saying
yeah i'm not saying that black men or
bad i'm just saying that
you have to understand why you lack
certain things and if the reason why you
like
black men and you're specifically on
black men is just to have the kids
then the black man is just an object
isn't it and after that you just want to
look for
little things that other it doesn't make
sense it doesn't make sense she's
probably living with like a caricature
of what she thinks an ideal black man is
going to be like
and so when she goes into these she only
looks for men who fit that state
it's hard not to judge booboo
[Music]
blame it on the rain
sorry i don't know why i even see his
face but i thought the the
the hair just i had to blame it on the
ring
like i always got the hair on the top
and then like the side saved yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
i'll just take that because you know i
think all right yeah
her blind date is hip hop dance
instructor muharrala good afternoon
give me your jacket please it's nice
my bit with ladies now follow me they
say if you can dance you're better in
bed
i don't know if it's not true
how do you know
what's your name hello nice to meet you
when i dance i start having an orgasm
oh wow the editing you probably did a
whole lot of things yeah yeah ended up
in the future you're showing the black
flip the only thing that you caught
was the kick up that's bad but anyways
we're just being bougie dancers right
now
what are you studying down here um i'm a
professional dancer
no please don't are you joking no yes
not a dance for living as well
[Music]
really are you ready to come through
oh yeah okay
oh lord lordy lord we're gonna eat
um no i'm quite special
i'm like allergic to loads of different
foods so basically can't eat dairy
products
eggs nuts kiwi banana beef
and like mustard and stuff i'm allergic
to latex as well
we're leaving that in we're leaving that
in
are we leaving that in she's off the
record i'm just
on record on the record wrong mind
look one i've literally never said that
and two i've always found it funny
because when you go to the doctors
when they're about to like put the
needle on you they're like are you
allergic to latex and i'm like
no but i'm like damn that's a real thing
yes because you have gloves that have
latex if you have rash on it
that's why you have latex living when
you whatever you have to but there's a
moment she's like
the black gloves like the the tattoo
artist right because they don't want to
take chances
but the moment she said that i thought
to myself there's definitely people
using that excuse yeah absolutely yeah
i'm allergic to latex i've never said
that you thought i should say that
no okay i hope not okay that's a weak
move it is a weekend yeah we'll never
that's a whack-ass move
if you lie to someone to be like oh we
can't that's whack but anyways
[Music]
thank you please don't get red white
no i hate red wine i'm for the wire
so this one i can't get your white girl
you're a dancer
yeah so you've either had
x being black or you're just into black
people no i i
have had eggs that are black um i am
into black men
to be fair really i don't know i just
like them i like a bit of chocolate
i think it's cause i can't eat chocolate
so i like chocolate man
okay what is it that's so gross about
this because i know if it was me
because you're an object yeah that's
what it is it's not
it's not my personality it's not even
that it's not what i say
it's not my smarts it's not this i need
a black man i need to fill in a position
you understand and you fit just because
of
what you think i am because of the it
has nothing to do with
who i am it's just you have the same
mo as the police
i fit the description just because i
look black
and that's what that that's what it is
to me it's the same mo
it's the same mo yeah and that's why
this is disgusting is
you reduce to just your skin not your
wit not your intelligence
not your character not none of that
none of that matters it could have been
anybody that's why i feel disgusting
when they say that when people say that
when when women went aw man my life's
kind friends man when they hear about
you know what i mean all that when when
when they say that the lights
they feel disgusted because they feel
like a fact that they're fetishized yeah
john paul stop said you must act out the
passion before you even feel it
and there's nothing you can do when two
magnets you know come together you know
they are just going to come close to
each other and they're just attracted to
each other
so that's quite exciting because you can
see it in their eyes they're showing
each other their teeth
like you're fishing you know and then
you get the fish and then you pull your
rod and there we go
you're witnessing something that's just
being born he's gonna be super
disappointed when this guy pulls her out
of the water on his fishing rod
takes a picture and then throws her back
in the water
shout out patrice o'neill what i really
want is i want someone to like
hold the door open for me but then like
smack my bum on the way through
the girl is bad but the guy is as bad as
her
he's buying and he's feeding into that
as well it's not just the girl
yes she said some pretty disgusting
thing yeah she's enabling her
yeah yeah well yeah well he's into it
because he's gonna smash but
i think the reason why i feel bad for
her is because the outcome that she
wants he's not going to get
because if all you do is you're very
just suggestive
about the bedroom stuff right away
you're climbing the dude's mind and not
giving them a chance to really see your
personality
so all we're talking about is the
physical aspect and we're not really
getting a chance to get to know each
other in that setting
i've had dates before where everything
was just super suggestive and super
pushy
and it became uninteresting because
there was no tension
there was no push pull there was none of
that it's just everything just like
and i'm just like and then later it was
like ah you know so
i believe i went down i believe that
slow it down not even necessary you have
to wait 20 days
i'm not talking about that even within
the date but give yourself a chance to
showcase who you are
outside the bedroom element in order to
really just see if there's a basis for
you guys to connect there
don't be mad when he doesn't want to be
with you afterwards he hasn't even
gotten a chance to really get to know
you
all he knows that you're very forward
and you're very open and you're like
black man
oh my god frankie and muharra's date is
approaching its climax
you always you think everything i'm
saying is so sexual towards you
if the date was a dance it would have
been
i think it was a bit of a tango it
wasn't romantic i tell you that
it was like it's work
i can't move in these trousers
that is the perfect example of what it
is to set yourself afraid
for failure that's what it is setting
yourself a failure that's why they like
leggings
yeah they are quite tight on my waist
i'd rather not have clothes
you rather have no clothes on yeah i
feel much more comfortable and i've got
nowhere please
she's a very good looking girl i think
this is going to be more than just i'll
see her once and i won't and that will
be it
yeah you'll see like two three times
and also he doesn't want to look like a
boy on tv
which i understand of course so yeah
yeah but he already knows no latex
well maybe maybe they're maybe they're
together right now
and they have lots of light-skinned kids
[Music]
he's so beautiful i can't concentrate
let fate decide what happens really
we'll just we'll just see where things
go in a situationship if
our energy's aligned and a ghost
relationship things go really really
well
maybe we'll escalate things slowly at
your own pace but
back in my bedroom potentially and yeah
you know
consent obviously that's not you will
use a condom but you're allergic so you
know we'll work things out however yeah
it's not you with me i'll call you back
for sure
for sure we can talk and like you know
maybe we can be friends
maybe we can do this every weekend and
yeah we'll just talk you know
[Music]
i'll make you wait um i will
i will make you late what a taxi home
[Music]
come on travel okay that was uh
this guy went in on her okay hey man i
mean that's good yeah he called the
spade that
that's he called the spade to speak that
that's that's all the signatures was
giving so
you know ladies even if you do have a
preference just don't go overtly saying
that don't make that i don't know it's
just kind of creepy when people do that
i said what i said
there's two bits and all the things that
you're going to say are going to point
towards one bit or another i'm not
saying it's good i'm not saying it's bad
i'm just saying
that's how i see that it is and yeah
i mean you know it's good that she knows
what she wants and that she's in touch
with it but
how you go about getting it also matters
uh
and also giving in to your urges may not
be in line with your long-term goals
just saying that's probably my only
thing
it seems like she was rushing to get the
dude to like her
and she didn't care about how she was
doing it
you know what i'm saying like that's
what she got
maybe that's how she thinks uganda
because because basically based off the
goal that she stated at the beginning
she wasn't working on it based on the
things that she was saying i'm not
saying you got to be faking all that
stuff
but it's okay to hold parts of yourself
back
i see plenty of women on a day-to-day
basis that i want to bone i don't
[ __ ] go out of my way to be like
right like there's a progress that i'm
going to make before i get to that point
she just laid it all out there and she
probably is very comfortable doing that
but i'm just saying may not get you the
results that you want in the same token
me going
will probably land me in jail it's not
where i want it to be
so that's pretty much it for today's
video tell us what you guys think do you
guys like black men
let us know no i'm good
[Music]
you came